大家好,我是Jim,這裡是AI Notebook
你換了一臺核心更多的電腦,誠實卻沒有快多少
你有沒有想過為什麼?
今天這一集,我們一起上史丹佛平行運算CS149的前六堂課
老師是Keyvon Fattahelian
我先把答案放在前面,平行運算最難的
從來不是算,是辦,算其實很快,把資料送到該區的地方才慢
這句話聽起來有點空,所以Keyvon沒有從頭影片開始
講臺上放了16張紙,每張寫著一個數字
他請一位同學上來
把他們全部加起來
我們就從這16張紙開始
你想像講臺上有16張紙
每張寫著一個數字
題目只有一個
全部加起來
K本請一位同學上臺
按下碼錶
這位同學一張一張往下加
花了大約40秒
答案106
全對
接著K本說
我們來試試看
能不能更快
他請了兩位同學上臺
換一組新的16張紙
一人8張
不過他加了一條規則
第二位同學要待在教室最後面
兩個人不準講話
只能靠一張紙和一支筆溝通
你猜猜看
兩個人
兩倍的人手
應該20秒左右就結束了吧
馬錶停下來
顯示41.7秒
答案一樣正確
時間卻幾乎沒有進步
多找了一個人
速度卻沒有跟得上來
他轉過身問全班
剛剛到底發生了什麼事
Kevin把馬錶的分段
一個一個念出來
兩個人各自加完手上八張紙
大約在第21秒就停了
接下來呢
兩個人開始舉手
因為不知道下一步要怎麼辦
到了第23秒
其中一位才站起來
拿著寫了小記的紙條
走到教室另一頭交給對方
對方再加一次
才算出答案
你把時間攤開來看
40多秒裡面
只有一半在算
另一半都花在走路送紙條
臺下有同學說出一個詞
通訊
通訊的意思
就是把東西從一個人手上
交到另一個人手上
人變多了
要傳的東西也跟著變多
每一傳一次都要花時間
Kvon接著問
如果重來一次
你們會怎麼改
一位同學說
我會邊算邊走過去
另一位說
我會直接用手機傳
這兩個答案
一個讓送跟算同時進行
一個按送變得便宜
整門課後面的做法
差不多都是從這兩個方向長出來的
Kvong又叫了四個人上臺
四份工作發下去
這一次規則放寬了
四個人可以站在一起
也可以講話
結果呢
不但沒有快四倍
還比兩個人更慢
原因是他動了手腳
他刻意把數字發得不平均
其中一個人拿到的紙又多
數字又大
另外三個人拿到的都是四啊五啊
這種小數字
一下子就加完了
只能站在臺上等
臺下有人喊出來
工作沒分平均
Kvong把這句話補完整
那三個人做完之後
完全沒事可做
這就是第二個教訓
決定總時間的
不是大家的平均速度
是最慢的那一個人
例如你在手機上
打開一個網頁
十張圖有九張一下就出來
最後一張卡住
你還是得等整頁跑完
你付了四個人的錢
最後有一段時間
只有一個人在做事
最後K本把全班都拉了進來
題目很簡單
這間教室現在有多少人
他給大家一分半鐘
先講好做法再動手
同學們提了好幾種方案
有人說一排一排數
再加起來
有人說大家站起來
自己湊成十人一組
再數又幾組
K本每聽到一個方案
都追問同一句話
那這段時間
其他人在做什麼
最後全班選了一個
最有野心的版本
所有人往前移
把前面幾排坐滿
再用排數乘上每排的座位數
馬錶開始跑
160個人一起站起來換位置
你可以想象那個畫面
走道上擠滿的人
大家都在找空位
跑到兩分鐘
轎池還在移動
沒有人喊出答案
K本在旁邊說
如果剛剛只派一個人
從第一排輸到最後一排
兩分鐘大概也輸完了
160倍的人力
輸給一個人慢慢輸
事後檢討
K本問全班
剛剛哪裡出了問題
有人說應該留一兩個人專門負責數
不要讓所有人都在動
也有人說
光是大喊這裡還有兩個空位
喊來喊去就花掉太多時間
A風把這些意見分成兩類
一類是分配問題
你沒有事先想清楚誰該做什麼
另一類是搬移問題
工作還沒開始
你就先花了一大段時間
把每個人搬到對的位置
你回想一下剛才那張紙條
也是一樣的事
大部分時間不是在家
是在走
接著他講了一句會貫穿整門課的話
他說
雖然整門課叫平行運算
但是我這輩子做過的每一個系統
真正決定成敗的只有一件事
通訊
還有把東西搬來搬去
他請大家接下來每一講
都把這句話記在心裡
這一集後面的內容
就是用硬體一步一步證明
他這句話是對的
在講硬體之前
Kvon先丟了一個問題
假設你去實習
主管給你一臺10核心的機器
10核心指的是
處理器裡能自己做事的單位一個核心
就像講臺上一個在加數字的同學
主管要你把一支程式變快
一個月後你回去報告
我讓它快了兩倍
你覺得你會被開除
還是被加薪
臺下分成兩派
說要開除的人覺得
十個核心才換到兩倍
代表資源浪費了一大半
說要加薪的人舉了例子
網站打開的時間少一半
客人就不會跑掉
一款遊戲從每秒15張畫面
變成30張
可能就是能不能上市的差別
K王說兩遍都對
有時候你在乎的是快不快
有時候在乎的是有沒有浪費
他說這門課雖然叫平行運算
他在乎效率的程度
一點都不輸給平行
就像剛才數人頭
如果一個人數一遍比較快
那就派一個人
不要為了平行而平行
那為什麼我們非走平行這條路不可
黑夢說有一張圖
學電腦的人大概都看過
行的是年份值的是一顆晶片上電晶體的數量
電晶體是晶片裡最小的開關
數量越多
能做的事就越多
這條線到今天都還在往上爬
一顆揮打的高階晶片上
大約有851顆
可是同一張圖上還有另外兩條線
一條是處理器
每一拍能做幾件事
另一條叫時脈
就是處理器一秒鐘打幾拍
這兩條線大約15年前就平了
例如你今天去買一臺新筆電
規格表上的10mai跟15年前的電腦差不了多少
電晶體一直變多速度卻沒有跟著變快
中間出現了一道落差
這整門課要做的就是想辦法把這段差距補回
10mai為什麼停住
答案是耗電
這個叫功耗
就是晶片吃掉多少電
這裡有個好記的關係
功耗大概跟頻率的平方一起走
頻率就是剛才的10mai一秒打幾拍
你把頻率拉高一倍
耗電要付出大約4倍
KBONG給了一個很有畫面的比較
一張RTX4090顯示卡全速在跑機器學習
它吃的電
跟你家廚房那臺梅波爐
在熱昨天的漢堡
是同一個等級
那些電最後都會變成熱
熱要是閃不掉
晶片就會燒壞
所以頻率不是不能再往上
是往上之後
多出來的熱
你處理不了
現在最大的超級電腦
耗電已經跟一座小鎮差不多
這條路走到了盡頭
速度只好從別的地方找
那個地方就是
讓很多事情同時發生
在多核心出現之前
那些多出來的電晶體
先被拿去做了一件事
偷偷幫你平行
這個做法叫超存量
意思是處理器在同一part裡
同時做好幾道指令
指令就是處理器一次做的一個小動作
像加一次半一次
Kvon在臺上寫了五道指令
前三道各算各的
互不相干
後兩道要等前面的答案
處理器自己看出來
前三道可以一起做
於是原本要五part三part就做圓了
而且算出來的結果
你寫的順序完全一樣
你根本不會發現
Kvon在這裡講了一個
他很在意的分別
橙色的意思是照這個順序做完
會得到這個答案
處理器實際用什麼順序去做
只要你看不出差別
他就可以自己決定
就像那16張紙
最後的總和是106
至於誰先加哪一張
答案都不會變
意思跟做法是兩回事
這個分別後面每一講都會用到
既然硬體這麼會幫忙
為什麼不一直做下去
Kven把剛才的例子往下推
如果處理器一次能做三件事
是不是更快
答案是不會
還是三拍
因為後面那兩道指令
要等前面的答案
你準備再多的時候
也只能一步一步拍著走
史丹佛早年有研究
專門問過這件事
如果完全不改程式
硬體自己能挖出多少平行
結果畫成一張圖
行的是處理器
一次最多做幾件事
值得是因此快了幾倍
曲線爬到3到4就平了
再往上加
也用不到
道理不難懂
你寫的程式本來就有先後
例如你要先打開冰箱
才拿得到牛奶
硬體再聰明
也變不出本來不存在的平行
三條路都走到底了
電晶體還在變多
頻率不能再拉
硬體也挖不出更多平行
設計晶片的人只好換個策略
既然我猜不到哪裡可以平行
那就請你直接告訴我
多核心就是這樣來的
它的第一步有點出乎意料
先做減法
每個核心裡那些花俏的功能
像自己找平行的那套邏輯
全部縮小一點
每個核心一直變笨
跑單一程式可能慢上兩成五
但是省下來的電晶體
可以在同一塊晶片上多放好幾個核心
我們回到那16張紙
這就像把一個聰明但很貴的同學
換成兩個普通的同學
只要你把紙分好
兩個人一起加
大概能快1.5倍
這筆交易看起來不漂亮
但是他能一直做下去
你現在打開你的手機
裡面也是多核心
兩顆大核心負責讓眼前的APP跑得順
四顆小核心處理背景工作
旁邊還有專門處理相機和神經網路的電路
不過都核心有個前提
你得給它好幾份工作
你原本那隻從頭跑到尾的程式
就像只有一疊紙
丟到雙核心的機器上
只會有一個核心在動
另一個在旁邊發呆
所以程式一定要改
而開封用一個計算
證顯值的小程式當例子
證顯是數學課學過的一個函數
你不用記
只要知道
輸入一排數字
每個數字各自算出一個答案
彼此完全不相干
這種程式裡面明明到處都是
可以同時做的事
處理器卻只看得到眼前幾道指令
看不出來
最直接的改法叫開執行序
執行序就是一疊交給某個核心去做的紙
你自己把這排數字切成兩半
前半一條後半一條
這樣確實會變快
可是你也把兩個核心這件事
寫死在城市裡了
換到一臺四核心的機器只用到一半
換到16核心只剩八分之一
你每換一臺機器就得回頭改一次
Kevin覺得
比較好的做法是換一個角度寫
你不要規定開幾條執行序
也不要規定誰做哪一段
你只要宣告一件事
這件事跟迴圈有關
迴圈就是同一個動作
每個數字都做一次
你只要說這個迴圈的每一輪
彼此都不相干
他在頭影片上發明瞭一個寫法
叫Four意思是
對所有元素做同一件事
而且順序不影響結果
這樣寫程式只負責說
哪些事可以同時做
實際要開幾條
交給執行環境
也就是程式跑起來
是旁邊那個管事的軟體
他看你手上的機器來決定
兩核心就開兩條
16核心就開16條
程式一行都不用改
這就像你只跟全班說
這些紙可以分開加
至於找幾個人來加
現場看有幾個人再決定
在C語言裡
有一套叫OpenMP的工具
你在迴圈前面加一行註記
它就幫你開好執行序
Kevin發現
剛才那個迴圈還有一個特點
每一輪做的事情一模一樣
只是數字不同
修照片 跑機器學習
畫遊戲畫面
大部分的運算都長這樣
一大堆資料
全部做同一件事
這叫SIMD
中文叫單一指令
多重資料
它做的事是這樣
一個核心裡
負責讀指令的控制器還是隻有一個
但是真正做加減乘除的算術單元
一次放8個
控制器說做加法
8個單元就同時對8個不同的數字做加法
例如你在手機上把一張照片調亮
每一個小點都要加一點亮度
做的是完全一樣
SIMD就是一口氣調8個點
寫程式的人常用一個叫NumPy的工具
處理大量數字
在NumPy裡把兩排數字相加
那個加號在機器上就是一道指令
架構師想得很直接
既然每一輪的指令都一樣
何必每次都重讀
讀一次就好
為什麼這樣划算
一個算數單元本身用的電晶體比你想的少很多
真正貴的是旁邊那一整套
讀指令 看懂指令 安排順序的控制邏輯
SIMD做的
就是讓8個算數單元共用一套控制
把這筆錢攤掉
臺下有人問
那為什麼不乾脆做8倍的核心
答案就在這裡
每多一個核心
你就要多付一整套控制的錢
SIMD只付一次
我們回到講臺上來看
就像請一個人負責念題目
8個人同時動筆
念題目的人不用請8個
代價是程式要改寫
每個數字都要換成一次裝8個的版本
K1自己也承認
改原的程式碼幾乎沒辦法讀
可是好處很具體
16個核心
每個一次處理8筆
整顆晶片同時有128筆資料在算
理論上最多快128倍
前提是
每一筆都做同一件事
不過這個前提不一定成立
K1換了一段程式
迴圈裡多了一個if
if
就是如果數字大於0走這條路
不然就走另一條
另一條叫else
問題來了
8個算術單元綁在同一個控制器上
同一時間只能做同一個動作
所以處理器只好先做if那段
把用不到的單元遮起來
讓他們空等
接著反過來做else
換另一批空等
在他的圖上if
那段有三個單元在做事
else那段有五個
加起來只用到一半多一點
然後他出了一道題
你能不能只用一個if
讓這臺機器只剩八分之一的效率
臺下想了好一陣子
最後有人想到
讓八筆裡只有一筆
走進一條很長的路
另外七筆走很短的路
這樣大部分時間
八個單元只有一個在做事
另外七個全在等他
這跟講臺上三個人站著等第四個人
是同一件事
這種情況有名詞
所有元素都走同一條路
叫做一致執行
大家各走各的
叫做分歧
分歧的程式
在SIMD上跑得很差
你的筆電一次
大約做8個
手機常見的是4個
繪圖處理器
也就是顯示卡里那顆晶片
可以寬到32
同一段有分歧的程式
放到顯示卡上
最糟只剩32分之1
所以顯示卡程式的人
一直被提醒
保持一致保持一致
K網講到這裡
把前面三個想法
並排放在一起
超存量
是硬體自己找
你不用改程式
SIMD是你告訴他
同一件事做8次
多核心
是把整個核心複製好幾份
三件事互不影響
可以任意組合
你可以把一顆晶片
想成那間教室
臺上有好幾個同學
每個人手上一次拿八張紙
還會順手先做不相干的題目
真實的晶片
通常三個都用上了
差別只在比例
講員怎麼算
K板回頭處理一個
一直被割折的問題
記憶體
記憶體就是存放資料的地方
對城市來說
它只是一個很大的陣列
陣列就是一整排
編了號的格子
你報一個號碼
它含你格子裡的值
但實際上
這些格子放在晶片外面
哪一次要走很長一段路
K板用了一個比喻
主記憶體像你家的車庫
空間很大
但每拿一樣東西都要走一趟
處理器旁邊還有一小塊記憶體
叫快取
它像你書桌的桌面
放不了多少
但伸手就拿得到
有同學問
那為什麼不把車庫
整個搬到書桌上
全搬都笑了
當然放不下
還有一個細節
資料不是一格一格搬
是一次搬一整排
這一排叫做快取行
在Intel的處理器上是64個位元組
位元組是電腦計算資料大小的單位
你只要一格
旁邊63格也一起被搬上桌
快取能幫上忙
靠的是讀兩件事
第一件叫時間區域性
意思是你剛用過的東西
等一下很可能又要用
就像你正在寫的那份作業
會一直攤在桌上
不會每看一次就收回車庫
第二件叫空間區域性
意思是你拿了這一格
接著很可能拿隔壁那一格
就像從車庫的箱子裡
把相簿往下翻
只要程式符合這兩件事
大部分時候伸手就拿到了
Kevin把等待的時間照比例畫了出來
最靠近處理器的那層快取
幾乎是一瞬間
往外一層慢一點
再往外又慢一點
一路都沒找到
要跑回車庫拿的話
要等上250倍的時間
他說你辛辛苦苦用四個核心
換來四倍粗度
資料擺錯地方
一下子就可能輸掉250倍
好處跟損失
根本不在同一個量級
麻煩的是
為了塞進更多核心
架構師剛剛才把快取縮小
算術單元變多
每秒要吃的資料變多
桌面卻變小了
還有一件事更麻煩
有些城市根本預測不了
下一步要拿什麼
例如你在網路上一個連接
接一個連接點下去
不打開這一頁
你不會知道下一頁在哪裡
處理器就會常常停下來
等車庫把資料送來
Kevin在這裡
問了全班一個生活問題
你們洗衣服的時候
會把衣服丟進洗衣機
然後站在旁邊
等他洗完嗎
大家都笑了
當然不會
你會先去做別的事
洗好再回來
第三個想法就是這樣來的
它叫硬體多職情緒
一個核心
同時記住好幾份工作各自做到哪裡
眼前這一份卡住在等資料
下一拍就換另一條來做
完全不用停
這個切換幾乎不花時間
硬體只是改一下
他現在看的是哪一份工作
這裡有個很容易誤會的地方
硬體都執行去
並沒有讓任何一件事變快
他做的是讓整臺機器不閒著
我們再回到洗衣機
你同時處理好幾欄衣服
這一欄在洗
你去晾另一欄
整個下午你一直在動
洗完的總量最多
可是其中任何一欄
從放進去到晾好
都比你專心只顧它還要久
因為它得排隊等你
Cable說這是兩種目標的取捨
一個叫延遲
就是一件事從開始到結束要多久
一個叫產出
就是一段時間裡總共完成幾件事
你想讓某一件最快做完
就守著它
你想讓總量最多
就在等待的時候切去做別的
硬體多執行續旋的是後者
它讓每一件工作慢一點
換整臺機器一直在做事
它還提醒
這門課講處理器快不快
幾乎都是在講產
那到底要幾條才夠
Cable讓全班一起算
一段程式先算3%
接著等資料12拍
就這樣一直重複
只有一條執行序的時候
大部分時間都在等
利用率只有20%
利用率就是
機器有多少時間
真的在工作
那要幾條才能填滿
你回想一下洗衣機
一欄在洗的時候
你要準備幾欄
手才不會停下來
他給大家20秒討論
有人喊出來
答案是5條
算法是這樣
一條卡住會空出12拍
每一條能補3拍
所以要另外4條來補
加上卡住的那條
一共5條
他接著問
那如果核心能同時記住8條呢
也沒有更快
已經滿了
多出來的只是浪費晶片的空間
再把題目改成先算六拍
答案就變成三條
算的時間跟等的時間
這個比例決定你需要幾題
講完三個想法
K-Bone把他們放回一顆真的處理器上
學生做作業用的那批機器
每個核心同時記住兩條執行序
Intel把這個叫做超執行序
那同時也是超存量
一拍最多可以把三道指令
送進三組算術單元
每組一次做八個
你會看到一個有趣的現象
只跑一條的時候
常常塞不滿這三組
因為一份工作裡
找不到那麼多互不相干的指令
多開第一條
情況就不一樣了
兩份不同工作的指令
一定互不相干
三組單元比較容易同時塞滿
不過K-1也提醒
多值情緒不一定都是好事
早年超值情緒剛出來的時候
兩條直情緒共用同一張書桌
桌面就那麼大
會把對方的資料擠回車庫
有些程式開了反而變慢
所以當時的電腦還讓你把第二條關掉
現在把三個想法疊在一起
你就會看到
一顆現代晶片有多難為寶
一顆有16個核心的處理器
每個核心同時記住4條直情緒
每條一次處理8筆資料
算術單元只有128個
可是要把等待的時間藏好
你再準備512件互不相干的事情給他
我們回到講臺上
這就像你請來一大群同學
手上卻只有幾張紙
大部分人只能站著
K文接著把同樣的算法
套到會達的顯示卡上
核心 執行序 每次處理的筆數
全部再乘上去
要把它餵飽
你得準備好幾十萬件獨立的工作
這就是為什麼
一個很小的神經網絡
撈一張很大的顯示卡上
根本跑不快
問題不在卡不夠強
只是你手上根本沒有那麼多事情可以交給你
就算事情夠多
後面還有一道牆
Cable用水管來比喻
一條每秒能流100公升的出水管
接上一條每秒只能流10公升的細水管
整條管線就只剩10公升
你永遠只能跑在細的那一段
電腦也一樣
算得多快不是重點
資料從車庫送上桌的速度才是
他把處理器跟記憶體之間的來往
畫成一張時間圖
處理器算兩下
就要一次資料
再算兩下又要一次
要資料的單子很快就排滿了
處理器這頭大部分時間閒著
他舉了一個最普通的例子
把兩排數字一格一格相加
就是你在任牌寫一個加號
一張現代的顯示卡要把它餵飽
記憶體的每秒送出100兆位元主
可是現在最快的記憶體
大約每秒1兆
算的那條水管
比送資料的那條出了100倍
所以這段最普通的加法
放在一張頂級的顯示卡上
大約只能用到1%的算力
有同學舉手問
那把快取加大呢
KBONG說
書桌再大
也要你會回頭用桌上的東西才有用
這段程式每個數字只用一次
用完就丟
桌子打也幫不上忙
有人問
事先把資料讀進來
他說就算車庫到書桌一瞬間就到
也沒有用
因為這不是延遲的問題
是平寬的問題
延遲是送一趟要多久
平寬是一次能送多少
你不是在等水來
你是想從一條每秒一兆的水管裡
擠出每秒一百兆的水
碰到這種情況
除了改寫程式
或者等下一代記憶體
沒有別的辦法
而且記憶體大約十年才大躍進一次
算力卻一路往前跑
這道落差只會越拉越大
改寫程式要改的是一個比例
這個比例叫算術強度
他的意思是
每從車庫搬一個位元組上桌
你要在他身上做幾次運算
剛才那個相加算術強度非常低
搬12個位元組只做一次加法
有同學問
那晶片為什麼要塞那麼多算術單元
可以幫我說
因為他本來就不是為了這種相加設計的
如果你這輩子只做相加
9乘9的算術單元都可以拿掉
幸好畫面和機器學習的運算不一樣
他們每搬一個位元組
大概能做10到20次運算
剛好配得上現代晶片
所以跑得動
他還講了晶片設計師做事的順序
不是先決定放多少算術單元
而是先算
我負擔得起多少平寬
再依照要跑的東西
決定放多少算術單元
你在這門課寫的每一支程式
幾乎都在跟這個比例搏鬥
想辦法讓每個班上桌的位元組
被多用幾次
有了硬體的全貌
K1才開始教怎麼寫
第一份作業用的程式語言
叫ISPC
是Intel做的一個很小眾的語言
他自己也說
網路上幾乎找不到討論
用過的人大概就是歷年修正門課的學生
再加上一兩百個
想把Intel處理器用到極限的工程師
選他的理由是
他非常貼近硬體前面講的觀念
會直接擺在你面前
在ISPC裡
你叫程式去做一件事
出發的不是一條直行序
而是一整組程式實例同時出發
這一組叫做一個gang
實例你可以想成
講臺上的一個同學一個gang
就是老師一次叫一整排上臺
每個實例都知道自己是第幾號
也知道這組總共幾個人
然後照自己的號碼
去拿屬於自己的那幾張紙
一組的人數
通常跟SIMD一樣寬
8個
這組實力其實就跑在那8個算術單元上
K1特別講了這個語言的一個設計
他刻意不用執行序這個詞
因為執行序會讓你想到
作業系統在排班
在切換
而這8個實力根本不是這樣懂的
他們是同一個控制器底下
一起動手的8個算術單元
這又回到那個分別程式的意思
跟他實際的做法
他說你讀一段ISPC程式
要先問自己兩個問題
第一
這段程式應該算出什麼答案
第二
機器上的每一個部分
在某個時刻
實際在做哪一份工作
很多學生來問問題
卡住的原因
都是把這兩題混在一起了
就像講臺上那個遊戲
你先確定總和是106
再去看誰在什麼時候
加了哪幾張
他也提醒
作業是在真實的機器上跑
多核心SIMD多執行序
超存量四件事同時在作用
數字對不上
通常不是觀念錯了
是幾個效果疊在一起
只要怎麼說
出哪些事能同時做之後
下一個問題是
工作要怎麼分給這些執行序
最簡單的做法叫靜態分配
事先把數字切成一樣長的幾段
每條執行區各拿一段
好處是完全不用協調
每個人一開始就知道自己要做什麼
Cable用一個程式當例子
判斷一個數字是不是指數
指數就是除了1和他自己
沒有別的數能整除它
問題是判斷指數花的時間差很多
數字越大算越久
你切平均的只是數字的個數
不是工作量
最後還是有人很早就做完
在旁邊等
這就是開場那四位同學碰到的事
只是換成了程式
所以他換一種做法
叫動態分配
所有工作排成一條隊
誰做完手上那份
就回來拿下一份
誰快誰多做
就像把整碟紙放在講臺上
誰加完就上來再拿一張
在城市裡
這條隊可以簡單到
只是一個共用的計數器
誰要拿工作
就把數字加一
拿到的號碼就是下一份
動態分配也有代價
那個共用的計數器需要一把鎖
鎖的意思是
同一時間只准一個人去動它
免得兩條執行去拿到同一份工作
就像講臺上那碟紙
一次只准一個人伸手去拿
其他人的排隊
Cable讓大家看計時
整支程式跑了5.9秒
他說
如果幾乎所有時間都在判斷指數
那就沒什麼好改的
可是如果真正在算的只有兩秒半
代表一半以上的時間
都花在排隊搶那把鎖
解法是一次多拿幾份
把每次拿一份
改成每次拿兩份
搶鎖的次數就少一半
這裡有一個取捨
工作切得越細
越容易分得平均
但是排隊拿工作的次數越多
切得越粗
排隊少了
卻容易有人抱走一大塊
拖住所有人
這沒有標準答案
K-BON自己的習慣
是把每次拿幾份
寫成一個參數
交作業錢再慢慢調
就算用了動態分配還是可能卡在最後那一段
長尾就是大家都做完了
只剩一件拖在後面
K幫畫了一張圖
16份工作
他刻意讓最後一份特別大
動態分配照順序往下發
偏偏最大的排在最後
等某條資訊去拿到他的時候其他人早就做完了
大家只能一起等他
就像講臺上那四位同學
偏偏最後的一疊紙最後才發下去
如果你事先知道每份工作的大小
有一個很簡單的改法
先發最大的
最大的那份一開始就被拿走
後面再用小的去補空檔
最後大家幾乎同時收工
他還提了一個進階做法
不要讓所有人擠同一疊紙
每個人各自一疊
自己的作業
就去別人那裡偷一份來做
這跟開場那四位同學是同一個教訓
差別在於
這次你有辦法事先處理它
還有一種平行
長得不太一樣
它不是一開始就擺在那裡的
K-BON用快速排序當例子
排序就是把一堆數字從小排到大
他用的是其中跑得很快的一種
你先挑一個基準值
比他小的放左邊
比他大的放右邊
然後左右兩邊各自再排一次
例如你再整理一疊考卷
先抽一張60分的
比它低的放左邊
高的放右邊
兩疊再各自往下分
一開始只有兩件事可以同時做
左邊跟右邊
但是每一邊又會再分成兩邊
一層一層往下
能同時做的是越來越多
最後多到可以塞滿整臺機器
為了好寫這種程式
有一套工具叫Silk
現在大部分C++的編譯器都支援
它只加了兩個關鍵字
Spawn的意思是交出去
不用等它你繼續往下走
Sync的意思是
派出去的都做完了
它可以繼續
K1提醒
先弄懂這兩個字的意思
別急著想他們底下怎麼做出來
Kevin後來把重點從分工移到通訊
你還記得開場那張紙條嗎
很多時候真正的成本不在
算在同學之間要傳的那些東西
他把通訊分成兩種
第一種叫固有通訊
是題目本身就需要的
例如你要算這一格
就一定得知道隔壁那格的值
這種躲不掉
第二種叫人為通訊
是你的寫法多製造出來的
例如資料擺放的不好
你只想拿一個數字
卻得從車庫搬回一整條
64位元主的快取行
其他60幾個位元組根本用不到
有例如兩條執行區各改各的數字
偏偏這兩個數字擠在同一條快取行裡
硬體為了讓兩邊看到的一樣
只好讓那一整排在兩個核心之間來回搬
就像兩個人搶同一張紙條
前一種你只能接受
後一種你可以重新安排資料和工作的順序
把它消掉
我們回頭看這一集
你會發現每一個想法都是在處理搬東西
多核心要成立
工作之間就不能傳太多紙條
SIMD要有效率
八筆資料的走同一條路
快取是為了讓資料少跑幾趟車庫
多值行驅是在等資料的時候
像等洗衣機一樣
先去做別的事
工作分配
是為了讓沒有人站在臺上乾等
而最後那道平寬的牆告訴你
就算前面每件事都做對了
只要每班一個位元主做的運算不夠多
整臺機器還是隻能用到1%
K-1在第一堂課說過
這門課要教你兩件事
第一件是看到問題就想
怎麼分成可以同時做的部分
以及他們之間怎麼配合
第二件是讓你知道硬體裡實際在發生什麼
因為不知道引擎怎麼轉
你就不可能讓它跑快
穿兩者的就是開場那句話
真正決定成敗的是通訊和搬東西
現在它不只是一句口號
是你算得出來的結論
我們回到開場那兩位同學
他們各自加完八個數字只花了21秒
剩下的20秒都花在把一張紙條從教室這頭送到那頭
這集我們從那張紙條出發
一路看到晶片上128個算數單元在等資料
看到一條每秒一兆的水管
恨不起每秒100兆的需求
說到底硬體給你的算力很多
用不用得上要看你怎麼安排資料
下一集我們會進到繪圖處理器
一顆晶片上幾萬個算術單元
要你準備好幾十萬件工作才為得保
最後問你一個問題
如果你手上有一段程式
在多核心的機器上跑不快
你覺得它卡在算還是卡在搬
留言跟我分享
喜歡這種把公開課講清楚的內容
也可以訂閱AI Notebook
我是Jim
我們下次見